it's hard to imagine going to a shop in
a European country and being denied the
right to buy a refrigerator because of
where you come from
or having to be more than the locals to
rent a car but that can happen online
this is called geo blocking a
discrimination applied in different
forms by 63% of european websites a new
regulation by the european parliament
will ban it almost entirely by the end
of 2018 what we have achieved actually
is that the online shopping and shopping
in the sort of say real world come
closer and closer together but nobody
can be discriminated on internet this is
a great achievement for consumers rights
and the Parliament is making sure that
it doesn't stop there within two years
the Commission will have to assess the
extension of the ban to films ebooks
music and video games we have very
intense discussions on the some digital
contents that we would like to be
included in this regulation so we agreed
that there will be a review of this
regulation within two years the
improvement of online shopping is a
decisive step towards the digital single
market in Europe
[Music]